we're now about 57 days away from the
launch of Apple's iPhone 15 lineup this
September which seems nuts because it
feels like we only recently got the
iPhone 14 pro Max which is a great phone
but it's honestly nothing compared to
the huge list of changes we're expecting
for the 15 lineup so let's go through 15
changes that you should look forward to
the first change that I think everyone
will notice right away is the new
rounded Edge design across the entire
lineup with a slight and subtle curve on
both the glass itself and the metal
frame with more precise Machining than
ever before so it'll be perfectly smooth
and Incredibly comfortable in your hands
and the best part is that the sides will
still technically be flat which we know
from this real iPhone 15 Pro leaked
image from unknowns 21 which reveals the
second big change and that is of course
the USBC Port which will finally put the
lightning port to death after 10 in long
years of slow transfer speeds which USBC
will finally fix with a catch apparently
the regular iPhone 15 models will still
support the old very slow 480 megabits
per second transfer speeds that plagued
the iPhone for years and it's really
unclear whether this is a drawback
related to the 816 ship or if Apple just
wants to screw with their customers and
make them want to upgrade to the 15 Pro
which will have at least 5 gigabits per
second transfer speeds or maybe even
Thunderbolt 4 which is 40 gigabits per
second which some leakers were
discussing but either way USBC will make
it much more convenient in terms of
charging all of your Tech products with
a single cable now on to the third big
change which is another huge bonus for
people who buy regular iPhone models
instead of the pros the ugly Notch that
iPhone users pretended was cool and
unique for many years is fine only being
erased for good yes all iPhone 15 models
will now come with Apple's Dynamic
Island feature which definitely looks a
lot better and does actually come in
handy now that more apps support it like
Airlines showing your travel info now
change number four is going to be big
for all of you Pros out there or at
least regular guys that like the sound
of a pro phone the 15 Pro Models will be
getting a major display upgrade and know
the actual display panel specs and
features aren't really changing at all
but it's actually the bezels that will
be getting a lot Slimmer so slim in fact
that they'll be the thinnest bezels on
any phone ever which is something that
really matters to me to make my phone
feel more immersive and I'm super
excited for this now change number five
impacts the entire lineup and just about
the best way anyone can ask for and
that's with the battery sizes getting
significantly larger across the board
from 12 inch bigger for the 15 Pro Max
all the way up to an 18 boost in size
for the regular iPhone 15. now this is
gonna be a huge deal because well I
probably don't need to explain it more
battery equals more good now before I
get into number six I want to show you
guys my absolute favorite shoes to wear
from our partner vessi this is my second
pair that I just picked up for special
occasions but I've been wearing my black
pair for almost a year now it can be
hard to find a nice shoe that's trendy
easy to slip on and gives you comfort
but vessies have it all and they are 100
waterproof so whether it's rain or shine
your feet will stay dry while you travel
or just walk your dog these are the
men's everyday classic in pearl white
and they go with just about every outfit
so you don't have to stress about
styling and my favorite part is that
bessies use a stretchy water proof
fabric called dime attacks and they slip
on very easily to make them super comfy
I truly believe that you'll love them so
check out a variety of vessi styles
today by using the link below to get 15
off your order with the code maxtech at
checkout now back to change number six
macsafe charging is finally getting a
big upgrade and allowing 15 watt fast
wireless charging with basically any
third-party qi charger that supports it
getting rid of Apple's artificial
imitation meant to push you to buy their
expensive Max save certified 15 watt
Chargers I for example love this
third-party macsafe car mount charger
since it's only 25 bucks on Amazon and
it comes with the cable and adapter but
it's limited to 7.5 Watts even though it
technically supports 15 watts well
thankfully when the iPhone 15 comes out
this one will instantly get an upgraded
to 15 watts of fast wireless charging
but I have a pretty good feeling that
Apple will increase the certified Max
save speed up to 20 watts to sweeten the
deal for official Chargers but we'll see
for change number seven we have the a17
bionic chip which will be exclusive to
the Pro Models this year and this will
be a big deal because it'll be the first
three nanometer chip in the world which
means it'll get even faster while using
less power further improving battery
life and not heating up as much as
before number eight is a very simple but
important change which is an upgrade to
eight gigabytes of RAM on the Pro Models
instead of the previous six which will
help for General performance and
snappiness while using various apps now
getting into number nine we have the
action button which is going to be
exclusive to the pros and it's basically
a button that will replace the mute
switch that we've had for so many years
but it's going to be better than you
think because it'll be fully
customizable to do basically anything
you want including instantly opening up
the camera app and taking photos
performing certain shortcuts and of
course toggling on silent mode if you
long press it number 10 is another
simple one once again for the iPhone 15
pros and that's the new titanium finish
which is gonna look really nice and
unique and probably attract less
fingerprints than the stainless steel
version but what's awesome is that it'll
be stronger than stainless steel while
also being lighter which is something we
learned from the Apple watch Ultra now
number 11 is the one I'm personally
excited for the most and that's the
Periscope zoom lens which will be
exclusive to the iPhone 15 Pro Max model
now this one is going to be unique
because it'll finally take the maximum
3x Zoom length all the way up to around
6X making Zoom shots look twice as good
but not only that that it's supposed to
be a variable zoom lens so it'll have
physical lenses on the inside which
optically Zoom from around 3x to 6X
without using any digital Zoom so it'll
have excellent quality for the entire
range now on the other hand number 12 is
that the regular iPhone 15 models are
rumored to be getting the same 48
megapixel crazy high quality sensor that
we just got on the 14 Pro Models which I
personally think is awesome because it
greatly increases quality for regular
main camera shots I personally thought
that Apple would wait longer to add this
to the regular models but here we are
for number 13 we've already had a bunch
of leaks pointing to the new iPhone 15
Pro Models getting Wi-Fi 6E which means
faster speeds because unlike Wi-Fi 6 the
new e-version will support the brand new
six gigahertz frequency which will lead
to a more freed up and less busy signal
and yet again another change that'll
give us some subtle yet important
updates for just the Pro Models is an
updated lidar scanner which will be used
to improve camera focus at night as well
as portrait photography and cinematic
video as well and finally for number 15
both the regular iPhone 15 and 15 plus
are rumored to be getting frosted matte
glass on the back just like we currently
have on the Pro Models which I think is
a lot better because it stops
fingerprints and feels nice and smooth
so there you go those were 15 changes to
look forward to on the new iPhone 15
lineup and I've got to say this is just
about the most excited I've been for an
iPhone especially for those super thin
bezels on the pro model as well as the
Periscope camera and a17 bionic chip let
me know your favorite change down in the
comment section below and click that
Circle above to subscribe for more video
feels like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
foreign